efforts are ramping up to make the
vaccine more accessible
another large facility opens here in the
valley tomorrow yakaholman live now at
texas station
with how the health district is updating
its plans to get more people vaccinated
hi bianca
those who need a coven 19 vaccine can
come here to texas station in north las
vegas
and they're making it easy that's
because you never even have to leave
your car
because it's a drive through so starting
on tuesday
texas station's first floor of the
resort's parking area will be a
drive-through
site those who come can get the first or
second dose of the pfizer vaccine
at the same time texas station is still
offering covet 19
testing this will help las vegas move
towards full reopening
removing capacity restrictions and
social distancing requirements
scott black north las vegas councilman
and health district board chair
says this location will target people in
north
northwest las vegas both those areas and
reach those who may be hesitating
hesitant to get vaccinated we've had
pamela goings-brown city councilwoman
going into the community
talking to people that that are trusted
getting people that are trusted within
the community faith leaders
political leaders community influencers
to talk about their experience getting
it and why it's so important so really
it's a multi-pronged
uh effort to to talk about the science
and the facts of it
and also just to convey a level of
confidence letting know folks said
that it's okay and it's worthwhile and
it's the best alternative
right now 500 appointments are booked
daily for the beginning of this week
they have the capacity to do 1 000 daily
now this vaccination clinic will be open
seven days a week
from 7 to noon starting on tuesday and
again you must make an appointment in
advance
reporting from rancho and lake me bianca
holman 8 news now